alright guys first video in my brand new
apartment I got everything set up
I had the posters it's all good let's
talk about Return of the King the Lord
of the Rings returned the King is a film
that geeks were just salivating for I
mean they were just like drooling for
this movie everyone wanted to see this
movie when it came out I remember going
to this movie I remember the crowds I
remember sitting there I remember the
anticipation level I remember all of it
it was all at this amazing height of
insanity and this film opens an
interesting way the first scene in this
movie is actually a flashback where you
see Smeagol first discovering the ring
and you see what happens the moment he
becomes enticed by it this is
interesting because a lot of people may
have thought that this would have been a
better thing to open the two towers with
because that's where you get introduced
to golems character and into towers you
see golems love of the ring and you hear
about how it used to be someone else but
you don't really get to know that much
about it Return of the King is really
the film where golems character gets
flushed out even more because you see
this opening you see how he first
discovered the ring and you start to
understand why he is so enticed by it
and why it's basically his life and in
this film even more than in two towers
Frodo and Sam are continuously drawn
apart by golems deception he keeps
making Frodo think that Sam is doing all
these things and Sam sees that Gollum is
you know he's a pretty treacherous guy
and Sam gets that Sam is smart but
further was messed up because of this
ring he's allowing people to deceive him
he's looking at his best friend he's not
understanding who he is anymore and this
adds so much character to this movie and
in my opinion is the reason why the
Return of the King has the most
understanding of the hobbits and has the
most depth for the hobbits in this last
film you get to see so much more happen
with these two characters in this movie
meanwhile everyone who ever lived is
preparing for the final battle of
middle-earth in which basically everyone
from every land is going to be going up
against our Mons armies to try to give
Frodo and Sam enough time to get that
ring to the mountain to try to buy time
for everything to happen correctly and
to basically allow the world of men to
survive
Return of the King is my favorite of the
trilogy it's very rare for the third
film in a trilogy to actually be the
best it doesn't happen to her
often and in my opinion it does here
Return of the King is a movie that just
pumps you up so much every scene has
this great feeling of anticipation of
finality of just epic standards that you
don't see in movies ever every time King
Theoden is running along the battle
lines and he's charging up his mana
knees and the red Sun rises I get so
pumped that's gonna take some Gatorade
that's how pumped I get but seriously
this movie is so enthralling each scene
just feels like it's happening it's
there you're in this moment and as I
said in my two towers review this is
really the film where Pippin
finally matures because Mary started to
get a little bit more serious in the two
towers when he was encouraging Treebeard
to go to war Pippin was still a child
until returned to the king when he sees
some of the things that happened because
of his fault when he voluntarily puts
himself under the submission of this
corrupt King Gandalf just rolls his eyes
and like I don't believe what's going on
here you finally start to see this
character mature into his own and what
does he do he sings a battle song it's
funny when I heard about that scene I
was like really
Pippin sings during the battles but
believe it or not it actually works and
that's a credit to Peter Jackson because
his movies directed so well that they
can actually show a hobbit singing a
song that's completely serious in the
midst of this very devastating battle
and it works what do you know now one of
my favorite characters in fact probably
my favorite character of this whole
series is Viggo Mortensen as Aragorn and
this is his film in a lot of ways
because the title The Return of the King
is in reference to him and this is a
film where he comes into his own as a
king and there is this great scene that
is so epic every time I see it I'm like
yes it's when Aragorn decides to go into
the mountain and find those ghostly
people and try to enlist them in this
war Legolas and Gimli are standing there
leg I don't think so man and Aragorn is
just like I do not be
death and just walks into that mountain
escape is all blowing it's incredible I
love that scene this is the kind of
movie where each scene feels like yes
like a like a yes moment and like where
certain movies try to make the audience
do that you know like the big patriotism
movies of today and everything yeah it
killed the bag I always said the big
line yeah you're supposed to feel the
pumped up and everything and it doesn't
always work Return of the King every
scene has a moment like that we're just
like mmm
Gandalf mmm Frodo like you just I am
such a nerd
I don't care seriously though this movie
has so much that a film lover would like
to see it's a film that's directed
beautifully it has actors that are
taking these really fantastical elements
seriously and it comes off so incredibly
well and it's one of the only times
where the Academy has actually
recognized a fantasy film of this type
it won every single Oscar that it was
nominated for including Best Picture
that has never happened for you know
like a geekdom movie of this type ever
and it probably never will it was really
inspiring for me to watch that happen
and as a series Lord of the Rings films
are some of my all-time favorite films
the battle scenes the characters the
music the epic scope of all three of
these films their unparalleled if you
haven't had a chance to see the Lord of
the Rings films but you want to see The
Hobbit coming up soon please check these
movies out you're not going to be
disappointed by them okay if you are
okay I guess you're disappointed by them
whatever I love them Return of the King
concluded this series beautifully it of
course gets an A+ so I'm going to be
seeing the Hobbit this Tuesday my buddy
John the flick pick is going to be
coming and seeing it with me and also
doing a spoiler filled review with me
look forward to that and as always if
you like this review then you can click
right here and get stuck my next